1740 wurde in frankreich eine kuh der
zauberei für schuldig befunden und
gehängt muss ich sagen beschweren kann
ich mich normalerweise eher weniger on
my name zypern herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video und windows
heute auf der website unnützen stellten
also eine website die ohne zu schwitzen
vorstellt der meistbesuchte ort der welt
ist las vegas über 30 millionen
touristen besuchen die stadt jedes jahr
ort
glasvegas ohne spaß ich hätte meine hand
dafür ins feuer legen können dass
entweder paris tokio london oder new
york ist aber noch nicht las vegas man
wir können jetzt einfach auf weiter
klicken dann demnächst dunkle schokolade
kann den menschlichen blutdruck senken
weiße schokolade nehme ich jetzt
eigentlich keine schokolade nämlich
kürten das ist meine story ein und
verweist mal bei einem kollegen und wir
waren im gym und war danach noch für ihn
bitten trocken und der meine frau ich
brett schokolade und schokolade reichen
periodika wir waren gar trainieren und
er meinte das ist gute schokolade also
wenn schokolade irgendwie relativ hohen
prozentanteil hat dann schmeckt die auch
scheiße einfach und das ist wohl gut
dann aber wir machen weiter mit dem
nächsten unnützen wissen und zwar im
amazonas leben rosa flussdelfine alles
rosa flüstert eine alter das ist
megageil ich dachte flüssen der schiene
werden delfine
de facto hier steht wenn sich ein frosch
übergibt kommt ein ganzer magen mit
heraus sobald der magen leer ist muss
der frosch wieder hinunter stellt euch
mal vor ihr wart feiern oder einfach so
irgendwann mal schlecht gewesen und
stelle ich noch vorher hätte dann
wirklich gekauft und hat den folgekosten
auf einmal liegt da ein ganzer
ja wir machen weiter haben immerhin vier
von fünf deutschen verwenden ihr
toilettenpapier sauber gefaltet
das
[Gelächter]
wie ist ein fakt den wir haben schon ab
67 metern wassertiefe wird pressluft
einer dauer taucher flasche giftig und
kann bei tauchern schlaganfälle und
krämpfe auslösen muttertag wie
gefährlich leben ein taucher der
weltrekord im rückwärtsfahren und
währenddessen geige spielen liegt bei 60
kilometern in fünf stunden und basta
okay was das ist ja eine ursache
zwischen weltrekord dafür dass jemand
geige gespielt hat während er auf einem
fahrrad rückwärts gefahren ist und das
ganze hat er tatsächlich fünf stunden
lang gemacht morgen kommt übrigens auch
meinen kanal auch ein video wo ich mit
max dumme weltrekorde auf stelle also
hen morgen meinen kanal abchecken blaue
augen werden im alter immer heller
ich habe grüne augen wahrscheinlich
verschwinden die dann irgendwann genau
in england gibt es eine extra telefon
hotline für richter die straftaten
begangen haben wtf das erste hörgerät im
jahr 1901 entwickelt wo mehr als
weltkino eine menge action auf die
bekannten und widmen sich gerade
polizist einfach nur wtf warum ruft sie
mich jetzt an
ich will ich nehme auf nur wenige
minuten später zum kopf der ruft mich
auf ihren sohn ein verhalten vor startet
je beobachtet und ist nicht bekannt dass
der vogel strauß seinen kopf in den sand
steckt für mich gerade doch diese
redewendung irgendwie steckt nicht den
kopf in den sand und kommt auch von dem
strauß der im land der website wird
gerade eingeblendet dass es ebenfalls
eine sinnlose gesetzte website gibt also
eine website wo ja sinnlose gesetze
vorgestellt werden ich weiß dankeschön
dank für den applaus habe ich mal wieder
mehr gut erkannt aber freuen wenn ihr
wollt dass ich in keine ahnung ein zwei
wochen mal auf sinnlose gebete reagierte
vorstellen dass man da und bei
verbleiben
hey schaffen wir fünf like dann mache
ich das nämlich 1647 schaffte das
englische parlament weihnachten ab
während des schlafens wechselt man
stündlich etwa zehn mal seine
liegeposition
das ist nämlich eine sache die ich auch
überhaupt nicht bei kanal um freundin
von mir zu verstehen
ein kumpel von mir zum beispiel sagt er
kennt nur auf dem rücken und nur so
erhalte so verschränkten laufen rücken
weil das am gesündesten halt für den
rücken hielt und wenn man alleine laut
dieser aussage zehnmal in einer stunde
seine liegeposition wegfällt
das nächste vielleicht insgesamt sechs
minuten wird damit bleiben die von den
römern wilden tieren vorgeworfen wurden
die tiere nicht verletzen konnten wurden
ihnen zuerst die zähne aus und dann die
arme gedrückt
was zum heiligen schreibtisch ihr müsst
euch das mal vorstellen wie krank da
früher war da waren die im kolosseum
oder so beispielsweise nahm dann die
römer ihre sklaven vom tiere töten
lassen und haben sogar den sklaven noch
für ihre arme gebrochen und die zähne
ausgeschlagen damit die die tiere nicht
angreifen durften oder konnten was für
eine kranke zeit das war's wird sagen
wir haben noch eben fünf hunde zu wissen
sachen die eben durch und feierte 315
gab es in rom 144 öffentliche toiletten
alles klar das wollte ich auf jeden fall
schlimmer mal wippen die
meistgesprochene sprache der welt ist
proto über eine standardisierte form des
mandarin und amtssprache in china alles
klassiker 1740 wurde in frankreich eine
kuh der zauberei für schuldig befunden
und gehängt muss ich sagen beschweren
kann ich mich normalerweise eher weniger
seit 1983 hat der weibliche brust umfang
in deutschland um durchschnittlich 4
zentimeter zugenommen wahrscheinlich nur
gegen katja kramer wird es unmöglich sei
die gewalt stange in einer minute zu
essen ohne dabei wasser zu krieg
30 salzstangen in einer minute ad mode
wassers
beger das problem
ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier um einen schrecken
erst wenn es für andere medien und
berlin nach und lassen sie auf die
glücklichen an der kompletten richtungen
[Musik]